[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité
la solidarité ne faiblit pas pour venir
en aide à l'ukraine la guerre qui a
débuté il y a plus de deux semaines sur
place entraîne un élan de générosité sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
reportage dans le nord a les couilles
otv à suivre dès le début de ce journal
et si du matériel par pour soutenir les
civils et les militaires en ukraine des
familles quant à elles font le chemin
inverse et arrivent notamment en région
parisienne c'est le cas par exemple dans
les yvelines comme nous le montrera ce
reportage de tv 78 dans un instant du
rire aussi dans cette édition c'est bien
nécessaire en cette période si
particulière
le festival les sérénissimes de l'humour
débutera dans quelques jours à monaco où
seront en duplex avec salim zeghdar le
producteur du festival et si vous
consommiez des légumes en buvant une
bière et bien c'est étonnant mais c'est
le pari tenté par une brasserie locale
dans la sarthe qui vient d'inventer la
bière à la carotte mais vous avez bien
entendu une découverte étonnante de la
rédaction de via lmtv en sarthe
plus de deux semaines après le début du
conflit en ukraine la solidarité reste
colossal en france si la situation est
extrêmement tendue sur le terrain pour
les civils partagé entre volonté de
défendre leur pays et de se protéger les
ukrainiens peuvent compter sur le
soutien moral et matériel des citoyens
français la preuve par exemple dans la
somme où des collectes se multiplient un
peu partout dans le département élèves
et paroissiens notamment apporte
vêtements denrées alimentaires et
produits d'hygiène un reportage de gm
houbron pour wéo tv la chaîne de la voix
du nord se place
des aliments quelques produits d'hygiène
louise et satine élèves de 5e
participent à leur manière à l'effort
collectif en faveur du peuple ukrainien
on peut pas à l'elysée et directement du
coup bas ont fait des dons des choses
comme ça pour les aider de notre manière
depuis ce matin et jusqu'en fin de
semaine les élèves de la cité scolaire
alfred manessier se relaient pour tenir
un point de collecte lorsque l'équipe
pédagogique leur a proposé de s'investir
ils ne se sont pas fait prier ils sont
concernés ils sont intéressés ils sont
informés ils savent parfaitement que il
ya une guerre en ukraine ils savent
parfaitement que des populations sont
déplacés et que des gens sont dans les
difficultés ils savent aussi qu'ils
peuvent agir et qui doivent agir et
quand on leur propose un espace pour le
faire qu'ils sont saisissent tout de
suite au même moment à l'église de
flixecourt une entreprise de transport
collecte les dons récoltés par la
paroisse de la commune du matériel
destiné à traverser l'europe on a des
habits tout ce dont un peuple en exode
pour avoir besoin en première nécessité
ça me paraît évident de dalles aider
ceux qui en ont besoin qu'il soit proche
de chez nous plus loin comme au cas qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui après un simple
appel sur les réseaux sociaux et en
seulement quelques heures hier l'abbé
nicolas jouit a su fédérer les âmes
généreuses une mobilisation tels que
l'homme d'église n'y croyais pas il ya
des gens de la paroisse qui ont répondu
présent mais il ya aussi des gens que je
ne connais pas c'est chez nous en fait
c'est en europe c'est chez nous c'est à
notre porte
est donc ces flux vraiment on sent une
mobilisation une fois les dons rassemblé
triés puis emballé le transporteur sera
chargé de les acheminer en pologne à la
frontière ukrainienne un premier départ
est prévu ce week-end
voilà et la solidarité je vous le disais
qui mobilise toute la france dans l'eau
mais également l'organisation bat son
plein pour aider les civils victimes de
conflits à trois un couple franco
ukrainien reçoit et stocke dans leur
maison les centaines de dons qui
affluent chaque jour une ampleur
inattendue que vous voyez sur ces images
associations particuliers entreprises ou
encore pharmacie se mobilisent écoutez
ce témoignage recueilli par la rédaction
de canal32
c'est pour ça qu'ils envoient avoir
quelques quelques au blouson et tout ça
mais
des comme ça remplit c'était hallucinant
on a trié jusqu'à 10 heures du soir et
on a réussi de doter le faire je suis
toujours inquiet pour pour ma famille
là-bas parce qu'il ya mon neveu qui
aimait pas dix neuf ans qui accueillait
en larmes et en ce moment et tous les
jours gervais s'est dit est ce que tout
va bien pas très bien on ne lance pas
très bien c'est comme ça mais en tout
cas c'est vraiment gentil ce que les
gens ils font un message poignant et une
mobilisation donc impressionnante
partons à présent dans les yvelines près
de paris où une franco ukrainienne vient
d'accueillir chez elle des compatriotes
qui fuyaient les combats ils ont été
accueillis en compagnie de leurs animaux
de compagnie un ouf de soulagement bien
sûr pour tout le monde même si
l'inquiétude quant à l'avenir de leur
pays est encore très vive à reportage de
tv 78 la chaîne des yvelines
anastasia et daria se connaissent depuis
longtemps elles ont fait leurs études
ensemble en ukraine au conservatoire
national de kiev dès que la guerre a
commencé le 24 février daria accepté que
son ami et sa famille viennent vivre
chez elles anastasia est parti avec sa
soeur marina ses deux nièces maria et
olga et son bébé alyssa ainsi que leurs
chiens et leurs chats en véritable
périple depuis kiev une journée on en
resta qu'hier parce qu'on espérait que
ce n'était pas vrai que c'était juste
pour nous faire peur aux gens et moi
c'est l'émotion après minute suivante ça
a explosé encore une fois déjà tout près
de chez nous et
entre une voiture on a en partie avec
les parents dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
les deux jeunes femmes ont mis deux
jours pour sortir de la capitale est
arrivé dans un petit village à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de la frontière
avec la roumanie
exténué enfin arrivés à la frontière de
la roumanie elles ont attendu des heures
pour faire 5 km en a tellement fatigués
on a tellement klapper la seule envie
c'est de s'arrêter quelque part elle
dormir parce qu'on n'en peut plus à ces
moments là ils ont dit au revoir à leurs
parents à
frères fils marie les moments
extrêmement difficiles
le père de darial lui est en ce moment
au front a terni yves une ville détruite
par les bombardements russes je sais que
mon père est il et il n'a plus
d'électricité n'a plus de gaz une à plus
de chauffage sachant qu'une prenne elle
fait froid il neige la ville est
entourée et pour ne pas sortir malgré
tout daria anastasia et sa famille y
croit à la fin de cette guerre pour se
donner de l'espoir elle joue l'hymne de
l'ukraine
l'attak le départ la russie en ukraine
qui était aussi le sujet principal de
l'émission spéciale face aux territoires
sur tv5 monde ce jeudi l'invité michel
barnier ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères et ancien commissaire
européen s'est notamment exprimé sur ce
conflit qui pourrait bousculer les
équilibres politiques en europe écoutez
le bonjour monsieur barnier jour deux
semaines l'europe a changé elle n'est
plus la même et on prend conscience que
la question de la défense si on l'avait
oublié est une question majeure je
rappelle que vous êtes un spécialiste
des questions de défense européenne vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur ces sujets
et vous avez pendant de nombreuses
années
dit répété qu'il fallait mutualiser les
efforts de défense est ce qu'on n'a pas
pris du retard finalement sur la
question de la défense européenne ça se
pose crûment aujourd'hui
on voit bien que c'est l'enjeu de cette
guerre d'une des leçons de cette guerre
que de renforcer notre propre sécurité
parce que ce que nous ne ferons pas pour
nous sur notre continent là peu de gens
qui allons le faire de l'extérieur à
notre place à nous sommes dans une
alliance quand on parle de défense en
europe il faut toujours rappeler que la
plupart des pays pas tous il ya
plusieurs pays européens qu'ils se sont
dits pays neutre il faut tirer les
leçons la leçon c'est qu'il faut
mutualiser davantage il ya une bonne
nouvelle bon état d'esprit actuellement
nouveau on le voit au danemark on le
voit en suède et en finlande on voit en
allemagne où l'allemagne viennent décidé
une augmentation considérable 60 gr 100
milliards de sans doute d'abord pour
remettre à niveau à bulle tver et
l'équipement national de l'armée
allemande mais aussi pour participer à
un effort commun alors la question c'est
y compris pour nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ces efforts nationaux est-ce que c'est
chacun pour soi dans son couloir ou bien
est-ce qu'on mutualisent davantage dans
des opérations extérieures quand il y en
a besoin et dans des programmes de
recherche et des programmes de
développement de matériel face aux
territoires avec que michel barnier est
à voir ou à revoir sur les sites
internet de tv5monde de ouest france de
nice matin et de france antilles et pour
refermer cette page consacrée à
l'ukraine une belle initiative venue de
toulouse dans la ville rose jumelée à la
capitale kiev l'ukrainien résonne tous
les midis depuis le carillon de la
basilique saint sernin un geste
symbolique mais important pour montrer
la solidarité de l'une des plus grandes
villes de france image et réaction au
micro de matisse gardant de nos
confrères de la dépêche du midi sur
place
toulouse est jumelée avec la ville de
kiev donc pour moi c'était important de
permettra la basilique saint sernin
d'apparaître sur cette scène tous les
jours à midi des carillonneurs vont
venir se relayer pour pouvoir jouer cet
hymne à plusieurs carillonneur de
toulouse et des environs qui vont venir
pourquoi on puisse faire sonner cet
hymne de tous les jours
dans le reste de l'actualité de nos
territoires cette semaine les
célébrations et les actions à l'occasion
de la journée internationale des droits
des femmes plusieurs rassemblements tu
lui en france dans les vosges d'ailleurs
comme partout ailleurs si les efforts
sont nombreux pour favoriser l'égalité
entre les sexes certains corps de
métiers sont encore soumis à quelques
idées reçues immersion dans un atelier
d'artisanat et recueils de témoignages
en préfecture à epinal par ludovic biya
et anne didier pour vosges télévision
des couples tout à fait singulière et
donc avec de la mousse comme ça est très
très confortable formé auprès des
compagnons du devoir pauline exerce
depuis quelques semaines seulement un
métier dont le nom n'existe pas si le
mot bottier et bien dans le dictionnaire
son pendant féminin n'y figure pas mais
de toute façon qu'on l'appelle bottière
artisanes bottier ou encore fabricante
de choses sur un tir annales cela lui
importe peu même si elle admet avoir dû
surmonter quelques obstacles de genre
s'arrêtera et de pied non vraiment le
travail de montage etc il ya des partis
qui sont encore extrêmement on va dire
majoritairement masculine c'est vraiment
des hommes qui sont dans ce métier là et
c'est vrai que quand une femme en tout
cas j'avais des collègues qui voulait
devenir monteuse si vous voulez vraiment
accéder à ces métiers là c'était un peu
voilà c'était plus compliqué on sentait
bien que c'était encore le monopole des
hommes un atelier découvert ce mardi à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des droits des femmes par ses membres du
club service soroptimist à l'invitation
de chambre de métiers et de l'artisanat
font naître de 150 métiers dans
l'artisanat est en fait pour l'instant
la parité la mixité c'est encore à
développer dans le secteur artisanal on
ya une femme sur quatre chefs
d'entreprises artisanales des ambitions
et des inégalités aussi évoqué en début
de journée en préfecture où une
quinzaine de femmes avaient été conviés
à témoigner chacune dans des secteurs
d'activités bien distincts aujourd'hui
tous les postes sont ouverts autant aux
candidats masculins que féminins et je
pense qu'il faut absolument qu'elles
viennent nous voir parce qu'il ya des
opportunités de carrière incroyable et
franchement elles peuvent s'épanouir
tout autant dans l'industrie que dans le
service sans vouloir gommer complètement
est systématiquement certaines
spécificités propres aux hommes et aux
femmes a notamment été cités ici une
sensibilité singulière dans l'exercice
des responsabilités politiques le chemin
vers l'égalité parfaite est encore long
une nouvelle étape pour l'allègement des
restrictions liées au co vide à partir
de 14 mars fini le pass phases finales
fini aussi le port du masque à
l'intérieur excepté dans les transports
collectifs les allégements bienvenue
deux ans après l'apparition de
l'épidémie dans nos vies alors est ce
pour autant la fin des gestes barrières
non ceux ci sont évidemment recommandée
dans les lieux très fréquentés et pour
les personnes fragiles en particulier
voilà dans cette lutte contre la
diffusion du virus le centre européen de
la céramique situé à limoges a dévoilé
il ya peu un nouveau masque
réutilisables et lavable composé de
céramique il permet de réduire l'impact
environnemental des masques bleu
classique que l'on retrouve un peu
partout dans la nature explications au
micro d'alain drummond pour cet aliment
sur place entre guillemets le point
faible des masques chirurgicaux c'est
qu'effectivement les utilise quatre
heures ou sur une journée en fonction de
l'application et puis on va les jeter
nous on s'est dit pourquoi pas créer un
masque sans consommables c'est à dire en
utilisant la capacité de la céramique à
être heureuse et donc à pouvoir filtrer
des particules c'est ce qu'on a mis en
place donc avec le biais du précis
masque ou là l'idée c'était d'avoir un
masque étanche donc avec cette
caractéristique la plus une filtration
que ça soit à l'expiration comme à
l'inspiration aujourd'hui il est il est
distribué on peut tout à fait acheter ce
masque là
comment aider à la préservation de
l'environnement cette vaste
problématique agit sur l'ensemble de la
société et notamment sur les
collectivités locales qui multiplient
les initiatives dans ce sens dans les
alpes maritimes où aller le voir la
communauté d'agglomération du pays de
grasse est en pointe dans la gestion de
ces déchets élargie selon des consignes
de tri bornes connecter pour inciter au
tri du verre ou compostage les déchets
organiques
ces dispositifs sont nombreux et
originaux vous allez voir avec ce
reportage de christophe rigaud sur place
mieux trier et recycler les déchets les
collectivités sont en première ligne
pour relever le défi de la transition
écologique depuis 2016 l'agglomération
du pays de grasse a décidé de prendre
les devants en élargissant les consignes
de tri les habitants peuvent désormais
déposer dans la poubelle jaune
l'ensemble des plastiques mêmes usagers
et le bilan est déjà très positifs les
premiers chiffres que nous avons sur
cinq ans donc on a vraiment un recul
font apparaître une évolution de plus de
47% de collecte supplémentaire au niveau
du tri sélectif pour recycler davantage
plus de 9 millions d'euros ont été
engagés dans la réflexion de ce centre
de tri avec de nouvelles machines pour
séparer le papier du plastique et triés
en fonction de la taille et du poids en
2018 le pays de grasse devient également
la première collectivité en france a
installé les bornes collecter de
collecte du verre klink en déposant
leurs bouteilles dans cette borne les
habitants cumul des points qu'ils
peuvent ensuite échanger contre des bons
d'achat dans les commerces locaux ces
gagnants pour l'environnement ces
gagnants pour
l'administrer dans la feuille de facture
du traitement des ordures ménagères on
enlève du poids donc ça permet de faire
des économies on avait à peu près 22 kg
par habitant qui étaient recyclés et
après toutes ces années où on a mis en
place klink est bien là nettement
progresser on est passé de 22 à 30 kg il
ya 8000 foyers utilisateurs de clint sur
notre territoire et grâce aux bons
d'achat récoltés par les utilisateurs
des bornes connectés 435 milles euros de
chiffre d'affaires ont été enregistrées
dans des commerces de proximité été
dernière initiative en date du pays de
grasse la valorisation des déchets
organiques
plus de 300 composteurs individuels ont
été mises à disposition de foyers
volontaires mais plus original des bacs
de compostage collectif ont été
installés comme ici dans cet espace
aménagé dans la ville on prélève tout ce
qui est plus sûr reste de préparations
alimentaires et on vient directement sur
ce site de compostage collectif on le
dépose à l'intérieur d'un des bacs pour
avoir le procédé de maturation du
compost et on obtient ensuite un compost
de qualité qui pourraient être
directement récupérés par les personnes
qui participent au dispositif un système
de valorisation des biodéchets qui
devrait être amplifiée à grasse mais
aussi dans toute la france avec
l'arrivée de la nouvelle réglementation
contre le gaspillage et l'économie
circulaire
favoriser la lecture depuis 35 ans la
bibliothèque schoelcher à fort de france
rend la lecture accessible aux personnes
malvoyantes ou aveugles 10 nouveautés
littéraires ont été ajoutés dans
l'espace dédié à ce public en ce début
d'année de nouvelles oeuvres mais aussi
de nouveaux dispositifs pour ouvrir la
lecture au plus grand nombre un
reportage de robin parisse pour vient
atv martinique sur place
ceci est un lecteur de livres audio
dédié aux déficients visuels
on peut sur celui-ci rayer le timbre de
la voix mais aussi la vitesse de lecture
sans cela on entend bien et c'est une
voix de femme
6 tirs et a déjà un bon stock de livres
audio dans son mp3 il estime l'appareil
très utile pour les plus jeunes pour des
gens qui malheureusement un accident et
sont devenus aveugles du jour au
lendemain s'ils ne sont pas habitués à
ça
à la perte de vue ces appareils sont
très bien avant cette nouvelle
technologie audio il fallait apprendre
le braille pour déchiffrer un texte une
adresse avec le service que propose la
bibliothèque schoelcher les défis visuel
sur une davantage vers les livres audio
n'est fait plutôt vers l'option depuis
1987 la bibliothèque schoelcher ses
vertus pour rendre la lecture possible
aux personnes malvoyantes ou aveugles
plus de 30 ans après nous sommes passés
aux nouvelles technologies et nous avons
mis en place un service où les personnes
peuvent
emprunter en pointe et des documents
sonores qui se sont décédées au format
daisy donc le désir c'est un nouveau
système de
documents sonores en fait structurés
dits nouveau livre audio ou été ajoutés
à la bibliothèque en cette rentrée
littéraire 2022
voilà de l'humour et du rire c'est aussi
nécessaire en ce moment et à partir de
15 mars monaco va devenir et pour cinq
jours le temple de l'humour depuis 2004
les sérénissimes de l'humour sont
devenues un rendez vous incontournable
pour les artistes et le public de la
côte d'azur pour en parler nous recevons
sales in the dark et le producteur de
l'événement bonjour salim on peut dire
sans prétention que tous les plus grands
humoristes sont passés par les
sérénissimes de l'humour
non oui on a eu tous les plus grands de
cette génération sont passés au cn itie
puisque ça fait maintenant 16 ans et la
16e édition que nous faisons des
sérénissimes par contre ce qui est plus
intéressant c'est parler de ce qu'on a
lancé aux sérénissime ce qu'on ne
connaissait pas comme tanoh qui
aujourd'hui et est reconnu comme un
maître si l'un par exemple vous avez
concocté une belle affiche pour cette
16e édition donc quels sont les artistes
qui seront présents au grimaldi forum de
monaco cette session
donc nous allons commencer avec timsit
qui viendra avec son dernier spectacle
sa dernière tournée
15 nous aurons ensuite le cese caroline
vigneaux nous aurons également le 17
jean luc lemoine avec son dernier
spectacle brut nous aurons également le
vendredi
18 un plateau d'artistes avec des gens
comme giuly par exemple sebastian marx
ou david azencot entre autres et nous
serons d'ailleurs en direct sur la radio
nrj au niveau national et nous
terminerons le samedi 19 avec roland
magdane nous vivons actuellement une
actualité particulièrement anxiogène
c'est important de cultiver l'humour
dans un contexte aussi troubles et on
vient de passer quand même deux ans de
kovy d'avec les confinements avec une
période très compliquée pour tout le
monde on enchaîne avec ce conflit en
ukraine je pense qu'aujourd'hui rire
devient une utilité publique et je pense
que notre mission même si en tant que
producteur c'est difficile parce que
c'est des moments du film il faut donner
envie aux gens de ressortir et venir
dans les salles de spectacle venait au
sirenis hymne de l'humour au grimaldi
forum du 15 mars au 19 mars venez rire
venait oublier un petit peu mettant
entre parenthèses pendant quelques
heures cette l'actualité pour vivre des
moments de rires et de bonne heure
merci salim zeghdar les sérénissimes de
l'humour se dérouleront du 15 au 19 mars
au grimaldi forum de monaco avec
notamment patrick timsit roland magdane
caroline vigneaux et jean luc lemoine
tout à fait autre chose maintenant c'est
aussi à partir du 15 mars que la ville
de troyes retournera au xviie siècle
pour accueillir le tournage du film les
trois mousquetaires du réalisateur
martin bourboulon à cette occasion la
ville se prépare et se transforment en
véritables studios de cinéma menuisier
et peintres ont pour mission de cash et
l'ensemble des éléments modernes de la
ville comme les gouttières et les
devantures de magasins objectif donner
l'impression de remonter quelques
siècles en arrière comme l'expliquent à
notre partenaire l'est éclair le
régisseur adjoint mathieu a vaut mieux
écouter le
genou notre notre objectif assure une
rue comme ici c'est déjà de choisir une
rue où on est le moins entre guillemets
de de pollution sont temporel et ça va
être de venir masquer tous les
anachronismes on a quelque chose de très
contemporain dans les rues ce sont les
interphones les sonnettes et c'est donc
pour ça l'astuce un de nos de nos
décorateur céder petit coffret très
léger comme ça l'intérêt en fait ces
sont des choses très mobile puisque les
gens continuent à habiter dans leur
maison donc nous à la dernière minute en
fait on a des petits coffrets comme ça
qui ont patiné et qui viendront être
posée en fait sur sur les coffrets donc
là celui ci n'est pas encore patiner
mais il prendra exactement la même
couleur et puis dans le film il n'y
verrait que du feu
voilà et pour être tout à fait complet
sachez que le film les trois
mousquetaires sortira en deux temps dans
les salles le 1er opus est attendu pour
le printemps 2023 amusez-vous donc d'un
peu de patience et puis vous n'avez pas
besoin d'attendre pour le goûter la
bière à la carotte aussi étonnant que
cela puisse paraître elle existe bien
une création originale d'une
microbrasserie dans la sarthe qui s'est
inspiré de la production de sa ferme
voisine si on ignore encore s'il a
consommé contribuer à consommer cinq
fruits et légumes recommandées par jour
la rédaction de via lmtv sarthe a eu
envie de découvrir comment elles étaient
fabriquées reportage d'hélène galiana
sur place le packaging et penser un
lapin et sa carotte trône fièrement sur
la bouteille car dans cette bière il y à
des légumes l'idée est venue un petit
peu en discutant avec des amis du gaec
le grillon à saint célerin on avait
envie de faire quelque chose ensemble
donc cultiver des légumes nous on
faisait de la bière donc il a fallu
trouver une idée donc on a exploré
différentes pistes on a exploré le
fenouil le concombre et c'est la carotte
qui est ressorti parce que ça nous
semblait être le produit le plus
atypique et rigolo pour faire une bière
locale
et qu'ils sortent un petit peu un petit
peu du lot après des recherches sur les
taux de sucre et des tests techniques
notamment elle pourra être commercialisé
quelques petits points techniques qu'il
fallait ajuster mais après quelques
tests on a réussi à sortir un produit
sympa et la carotte amène vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant ça amène de
la rondeur et un côté très floral à la
bière et comme rien de ce père les
restes de carottes partent chez les
voisins les carottes la pulpe de carotte
qui va nous rester va pour un élevage
porcin
c'est le la ferme des champs rom est
donc juste à côté et qui vont
transformer aussi ses carottes en
produits locaux en viande de cochon
seulement 2000 litres de bière à la
carotte sont produits dans cette
brasserie de mamers
direction le département du val d'oise à
présent pour terminer cette édition la
nouvelle exposition temporaire du musée
archéologique locale propose une
exposition originale les spectateurs
sont invités à découvrir l' empire
romain grâce à des maquettes en lego si
cela peut sembler a priori enfantin il
n'en est rien cette exposition est
fidèle à la réalité historique elle a
été réalisée par un couple belge
spécialiste du monde romain un reportage
et des explications de michaël joly pour
vyas 95
des scènes de bataille un jules césar et
son célèbre veni vidi vici le tout en
lego c'est ce que propose le musée
archéologique du val d'oise avec sa
nouvelle exposition temporaire gris
quantique présenté pour la seconde fois
en france c'est 25 maquette plongent les
visiteurs au coeur de l'empiré romain et
malgré son aspect enfantin elle se veut
fidèle à la réalité historique grâce aux
connaissances de ses concepteurs un
couple belge qui réalise des maquettes
depuis 2013 cathy sas et archéologue
elle est spécialiste de l'antiquité
romaine
son mari s'est traduit relire les
langues latines et grecques mais il est
président d'une association de lego et
c'est lors de des 50 ans de
l'association d'archéologie romaine que
dirige cathy
quelles sont choisis de mettre à hauteur
d'enfant mais pas tous au final
archéologie romaine à travers des
maquettes l'écho mode de vie comme cette
représentation de rituels funéraires
croyances religieuses ou encore
architecture ils sont présentés de
maquettes reconstitue aussi le
patrimoine local avec le sanctuaire
gallo romain de génin ville la première
une coupe du temple seul bâtiment dont
il reste des vestiges aujourd'hui la
seconde une vue générale du site conçu
avec treize mille pièces s'y trouve le
temple et un amphithéâtre
aujourd'hui disparu on pouvait avoir du
théâtre des scènes de danse de nîmes ça
pouvait être un lieu d'échangé et de
débat civique citoyens et puis dans
l'arène des combats de gladiateurs de la
chasse on estime qu'ils pouvaient
acquérir jusqu'à 8000 spectateurs
l'exposition est visible jusqu'en
septembre 2022 l'entrée est libre et
gratuite
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous dans une très prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]